(dramatic music)
(sobs)
- You're awake from your coma
Hallelujah , it's a miracle!
- Baby.
What's this book?
- Oh, I pray now.
Oh yes, and I saw my rosary.
Since you were in this
coma, a lot has changed.
Sign this.
Is this divorce papers?
- How do you expect me to
marry the love of my life
without a divorce from you?
- Hey, babe. Look.
I'm trending on Snapchat.
- Ah, that's great, baby.
Because we'll be chattin'
about my snatch tonight.
Oh yeah.
- What is Snapchat?
How old is that kid?
- Don't you worry about it.
He gave me three
beautiful children.
More than what you could do.
- He gave you children?
That seems very quick.
(sighs)
Baby, we're supposed to
stay together forever,
like Brad and Angie.
- Oh shit, honey,
they even split up.
- No they didn't!
- Yes they did.
- [Man] No they didn't!
- [Woman] Yes they did.
- Why?
Well, at least they're gonna be
sharing custody of those kids.
I know that for a fact,
'cause there is a lot
of love in that house.
- Actually, Angelina
wants full custody
(shouts)
- You're killing me!
Why?
Brad Pitt is the perfect human.
- Would you grow up?
Breakups happen. Now
sign the damn papers.
- Yeah, I'll sign
these damn papers.
But it is gonna take a lot
of One Direction ballads
to get over these two breakups.
- No it ain't, One
Direction broke up too.
(beeping)
Ah, hell to the
no. Wake yo ass up.
You, no.
- Stand back, are you his wife?
- Yes, still!
Stop it, stop it, stop it.
Go, go to the light.
Go to the light!